talking about quantum I think long title
I'll let you explain yeah well thanks
for coming so let's see so I'm gonna
tell you I mean specifically I'm gonna
tell you about an algorithm that solves
a particularly a question that's in
condensed matter physics but I
understand that that's sort of a kind of
problem that people around here are not
familiar with or wouldn't necessarily
think about it so it's not really how
I'm gonna present the talk and it's not
really why I'm giving the talk and the
reason I'm giving the talk is that the
kind of question that this at this sort
of answers is the kind of is lives in
the kind of space that that things that
are types of problems that are more
likely to have been encountered by
people in science so so let me tell you
what it is that in general that this
problem is it's suppose you have an
exponentially large matrix that you're
given to you in some way that is
succinctly sort of it only takes you
polynomial time to get the information
for this exponentially size matrix and
you're interested in finding a principal
eigenvalue and the principal eigenvector
for this matrix and so and I'll give you
I'll even give you something that in in
hindsight is absolutely necessary which
is I'll give you a guarantee that what
you're looking for can be succinctly
described so you get this sort of
exponential size matrix that's given to
you six six we and a guarantee that the
eigenvector that you're looking for or
whatever other property you're looking
for is also synced and now the challenge
is to do it so phrase that way right
it's it's um it should feel a little
more familiar right it's sort of the
there are things in this in this week's
you're seen that you have to do with
that right so you know s estimating
permanence falls in this sort of
framework estimating partition functions
Gibbs gives distributions icings and
path models they all fall in this
picture if you if you want to put it
there
so so my goal is to sort of give you
less about the details about the
solution details that would pertain to
the actual pond mechanical problem that
I'm talking about in more the sort of
the bigger picture
peel four four four what these things
are so so alright so having said that
let me tell you what the actual problem
is that we're gonna be working on and
but but don't be too concerned if Austin
they're not going to be that many
details so let's try to trim it down so
okay so what's this exponential space
that we're gonna be thinking of which
has an exponential matrix it's gonna be
a tensor product of n copies of a some
finite small dimensional space you can
think of this as CD as to see if it's
two dimensional space u tensor up a
bunch of times okay so that's the space
on which the operator is going to act on
and let me tell you what the operator is
that we're looking for it's a local
Hamiltonian so what does that mean
there's there gonna be a bunch of local
terms so there's a chai is going to be
consider it as like a d squared by d
squared matrix so it's gonna act on two
copies which will specify each H I will
act on potentially two different copies
as a d squared by d squared matrix and
then act trivially on the rest so
tensors with the identity on the rest
okay so here here's so each H I is gonna
be a different one of these matrices
somewhere else and I'm gonna add them
all up and that's gonna be the big
matrix that I'm interested in
understanding something about so this is
called the local Hamiltonian and
typically for physics type things we
think of a little more structure on both
this space relative to what these local
terms are so we think of the so here the
blue dots will represent copies of the d
dimensional space and a black line will
be a particular d squared by d squared
matrix and if the black line indicates
the two copies of the space that what is
interested in so in the case of a line
these are just nearest neighbor
interactions so the lattice again
nearest neighbors neighbors so this is
so these are the types of things that
physicists really do care about
so those are those HS are not unitary no
there there sorry so I should have said
that so they're positive norm one
founded matrix so self adjoint positive
fountain or the spectrum between zero
and so so so what does this have to do
with physics well there's a way you know
there's sort of a model of interactions
that sort of say that heya system looks
basically like this at least as an
approximation and that what we were
interested in doing is finding out what
the low energy or the ground ground
energy which is the lowest eigen value
or the near lowest eigen values and
eigen vectors what they look like
because those the properties of those is
gonna be is gonna be helpful for
describing what the system is gonna do
so okay so that's just sort of your
background but again just you know just
think about it as the way I'm gonna the
framework then I'm gonna say is that
this is an exponential this is a matrix
of next financially large space we're
looking for this these low eigen value
vectors I which is okay so yeah and jump
in with questions whenever okay so all
right so if you adopt this framework
that I'm gonna I have to live in this
exponentially other space your first
challenge is look if I give you a vector
in the second measure space it's gonna
take you exponential time to just look
at all of its coefficients right so
clearly we're constrained in this way
right so how do you even do anything
right because you all these vectors you
can't even describe them let alone
figure out which one it is that you want
to be looking for right and so all right
so that's all right I've said you know
most vectors don't have a succinct
description so here's the okay here's
the big picture intuition to say hey I
don't have to I might not have to worry
about this as much as it first seems
which is that well you know these the
particular problem that we're looking
and looking
comes from a physical rendition of a
physical kind of thing and maybe
physical physical states are are somehow
a little simpler and so maybe something
this image emerges that maybe there's
sort of a small corner of this big space
which we can't really work with but
maybe there's a small corner where
things are can be sort of succinctly
described where the things we're looking
for actually are right and if that turns
out to be K so a baby then this problem
is tractable in some way okay and so
okay so what what what is the sort of
intuition around what that smaller space
should look like it's if there's a
heuristic that basically goes like this
that that when we're looking at low
energy states entanglement across from
from the left part of the system to the
right part of the system and so I know
most of you entanglement doesn't mean
much so bear with me for a second just
use it as a word and I'll explain in a
second but that there's some sort of
connection between the left side and the
right side that should be relatively
small compared to a general vector okay
so let me tell you what entanglement
means so the mathematical way that I'm
going to sort of phrase it is if I was
to describe the state in the tensor
product as a sum of component pieces
where the component pieces are vectors
on the left side 10 surd with vectors on
the right side level of an entanglement
I'm going to measure is how many terms
do I have to take so how many of how
many terms of this sum so for
generically for a vector I would have to
take an exponential number of terms but
how many times do I have to take for a
particular state and and so we're gonna
sort of there's a reason physical
intuition says hey it shouldn't be that
much the entanglement should be less and
so the number of terms I should be able
to take should be less and let's do
something that's reasonably less like
polynomials so I'm gonna sort of say
let's let me sort of imagine that the
things that I care about have the
property that if I cut it in half and I
express things as a tensor product of
left halves and right halves and I sum
them up that I can find some description
of those
choices of those left and right halves
so that that sum is only involves a
polynomial number okay and I'm gonna say
hey you know there's nothing really
special about the middle so I'm gonna
say hey you know that properly is
probably gonna hold no matter where I
cut it as long as I keep the geometry
relative so it's the longer they split
it left and right that should be true
and so let me hypothesize that those are
vectors of interest and let me try to
work with those can either talk exact or
we can say you know approximately in l
2-norm exact so that there may be if a
bunch of other terms but the mass the
complete mass about the okay so for
people for whom you know entanglement so
I so let me phrase this in terms of
probability distributions which is not
an exact correlation but it it's it
should give you the feel for it right so
you can imagine suppose I was just
dealing with something that is more
familiar which is a probability
distribution on n on an N bit on bit
screen strings that you have somehow
described right and this this would sort
of the analogous to this would be
somehow that the the correlations from
left to right are sort of not to much
and what we mean by not too much is that
you could describe this probability
distribution by first sort of flipping a
coin to determine which of some
polynomial number of different
distributions to search from which would
correspond to one of these B choices and
then you could sample independently from
the left side on the right side so
that's the end that's the probabilistic
an analogy to what to a meaning of what
this yes so and that B would be also
would be the rank if you thought of this
vector as a map from this space to that
space then it would be the rank of the
metrics and for people who know I don't
know sorry the words escaping right the
Schmitt decomposition this is just the
sort of number of the number of terms in
the Schmitt decomposition
okay so again you know we're gonna sort
of say hey let's suppose that these
these are reasonable vectors to think
about and let's concentrate on those and
it turns out that those have a very nice
very very nice computational way of just
sort of thinking about them they're
called matrix product states and this B
is is termed the bond dimension of them
and I'm not going to say very much about
them and we can talk about them more
later they're very expressive class of
states I'm gonna depict them by a
picture like this all right which is how
they are if if for those of you who know
tensor networks this is the tensor
network that would describe a matrix
products State and so let me just sort
of just just so that you have a picture
in mind
each of these ends that are coming down
here you should think of as the
component copies of C to the D we're
talking about right this green stuff is
some sort of information that we gave
that that inside each green dot is going
to be some array of numbers small small
number of numbers that's gonna be the
succinct description and these lines
here are going to encode the remember
there is this number B which was the sum
of the number of terms there's some how
that is going to correspond to the
thickness of this line so think of the
thickness of this line is how entangled
things are and that together I can give
you sort of information with if I give
you information about all these green
things that defines a state and this is
called a matrix product statement so
okay so what are the features of this
this is an example of this class of
succinctly described vectors that live
in our exponentially large space how
much data do I need to give you the
order of n times V times B squared is
the amount of data so it's polynomial
and n as long as B is polynomial and D
we were setting to be some kind of small
constant and the key is that we can do
we can do linear algebra with these guys
even though they live in an
exponentially large space we can do
things like compute inner products with
them okay so if I give you two of these
describe things succinctly describe
things there are two vectors in this
very large space I can succinctly
compute and products
you cannot add them right with that you
you for a while you can add them so that
when you add them the bond dimension
goes up so first if you have if you want
to do a little bit of linear adding you
can but not too much before your the
bonds get if you're limiting how much
the bomb isn't
okay so all right so now we've got these
sort of physically relevant relevant
states and let's go back to this
original problem this was the problem of
trying to find this these these
eigenvectors of this particular matrix
and so there was there were
computational huge there was the history
of success on this problem goes back to
the 90s with white who had an algorithm
that it was heuristic but there was
incredibly effective very surprisingly
so I named it was called the density
matrix renormalization group was sort of
the name of the of the sort of the
algorithm it was very successful I
didn't work all the time but it was very
successful and it was successful in all
kinds of places that were pretty
surprising and has been continued to be
kind of the the go-to way of going about
it
and there's there wasn't originally
thought of this way in hindsight here's
here's the way to think about it which
is that we have an onset that the that
the answer we're looking for is one of
these matrix product states all right so
this is the sort of this is where we're
gonna go and we're gonna do variational
optimization within that structure so
we're gonna sort of take this guy right
where all these parameters are allowed
to bury over everything and we're gonna
start marching around burying these
parameters trying to optimize so we're
kind of bypassing this exponentially
large space because we're just sort of
variational parameter ization line you
know these are parameters they're no
longer is there this linear space in the
foreground anymore and we're just
varying a lot along those okay so okay
so there were places where this
algorithm got stuck and didn't do well
and people sort of wondered well you
know this is an assumption there's an on
sites that the answer should be in this
place like how is this a reasonable
assumption so when it works we say yes
it's a reasonable assumption because we
can check that it's that's in fact it's
it's a good answer to the question so
but when it doesn't work it wasn't sure
so there's the basic question which was
is that our
when it doesn't work are we looking are
we are we is it hopeless because we're
not looking for the in the right place
and so people started to come up with
criteria under which are sort of musings
about criteria that seemed reasonable
and let me just sort of start I've
forget the right-hand side of this
picture for a second but let's just look
at the left side of the picture so this
is supposed to be a representation of
I'm gonna I'm gonna sort of plot the
spectrum from 0 up for the Hamiltonian
from 0 up to n which is the biggest it
could be if it had in terms and I'm
gonna put a little tick mark wherever I
see an eigen value right and if there's
if it's a multiple space if it's if it's
a degeneracy I'll put many tick marks
there so there is a notion so again the
spectrum goes from 0 to n for those
people who actually have thought about
Hamiltonian sometimes there's a
confusion where people often talk about
the normalized Hamiltonian which is u
divided by N in which case your spectrum
should lie between 0 & 1
ok but I'm talking about between 0 and n
and I'm gonna say let's look at the
cases where the there is a constant size
gap between the ground state and the
second-largest state so the ground state
is the lowest eigen value and the second
most negative so let's focus on those
guys right so so if you normalize the
amyl Tony and then that says that
there's a you know constant over N gap
between the bottom one and the second
bottom one and so in that situations
Hastings and it took until oh seven for
somebody to do this proved that for
those hamiltonians
that in fact this matrix product state
yes that there should be the answer
should be describable by a matrix
product state with low bond dimension
right that was done in O seven and for
people again who are familiar with these
kinds of things it's a form of an what's
called an area law okay which sort of
which goes back to the original picture
which is that these states should have
not too much entanglement across from
left to right all right so this was so
one way to think about this is we show
that the answer to these problems don't
have so much entanglement from left to
right
so then sort of in this very abbreviated
version of the history that this doesn't
include a lots of different things the
next progress was that for these same
types of systems an algorithm was come
up that actually showed how to get them
and that's not the algorithm I'm going
to be talking about but a lot of the
ideas that went into that algorithm went
into this one too and after that there
was a second algorithm that was
fundamentally sort of in philosophy was
different and that's why I'm talking
about this one and not that one and it
it it's called aaarrrg for rigorous
renormalization group so renormalization
group is a physics idea and rigorous
applies to the fact that this is
provable results about them about how
well the algorithm does and the system
this the system for which it says
something about is a more general
configuration in terms of spectrum it's
it's the right-hand picture which is
that you've got a ground state and no
longer do you need to have nothing for
until a constant later now as long as
you only have a polynomial of things
number of eigenstates between here and
the and the next and some constant then
then all these states should be
describable all these states are we can
find them and they'll all have these
matrix product state descriptions and
and sort of so this was a this was a
this was a proof of a you know in
principle and algorithm and then this
algorithm has been the sort of
preliminary implementations of it has
doing and there's there's I'd sort of
say it's it's it's promising in terms of
being able to answer questions that
weren't answered before and be maybe
being able to sort of introduce a new
set of ideas and that that would make
things change things around a bit okay
so right okay
yes so hazing didn't say how to find it
it just showed that it had the
entanglement properties that you needed
to be described over volume matrix
is it true that if you about the number
of cements and you operator you can
balance maybe by much bigger violently
number of summands and that vector that
you would go for so is it true yeah if
you just get one then I can clearly see
that yes if two for example yeah the
reason reason that one can is because
it's a problem on a small space maybe
even two probably on this because it
ends up being on a small space so you
you kind of would need to cover order n
space to be even talking about a problem
that's lives on an exponential one in
terms of the other
I mean not yet non-trivial I don't think
so no you can have
maybe that's an even if there's a
trivial bump you just have some curves
you raise it to a power the bottom to
mention it most the reason you're
talking about operators are you talking
about the eigenstates of those offices
in terms of the operator series so
there's probably an exponential valve
right but that's just a bound because
nothing in the space can have that yes
so there's no no there's no there's no a
priori there's no pause there's no kind
of this is this is pretty generic in
terms of what the ground state can be
but what what is in generic is once you
sort of play around with the spectrum so
there are examples where the spectrum is
much more concentrated than this for
which the ground state is highly
entangled oh and I should have said
sorry I should have said wave before
which maybe you know would have helped
me not lose some people along the way
that this is the quantum analog of
constraint satisfaction right so in
constraint satisfaction problems right
you sort of you just sort of say okay
I've got a few I'm gonna I'm gonna put a
local constraint on a some number of
bits right so this these this would be
sort of a constraint satisfaction
problem where you know you were just
talking about constraints on nearest
neighbors
well since you mention a no like a
classical on like what would be bicycle
panels of castings and your statements
is it is a knee
yeah I think in the there isn't because
your solutions are all completely
uninterested in the one and this
we've been robbed of this would be the
fittest in the evening more exactly he
escaped and one came in a positive point
light enough
well in classical walk you may consider
not but not I think more generally in
classical rate when we talk about
solutions we're talking about product
states right that in that sense because
everything's diagonal in in the same
basis and so they so there we won't have
it entanglement show up but maybe we
yeah okay so okay so are all the systems
so now let's talk about what what this
so I'm gonna talk about sort of the
ideas that will go into this a bit ok so
I want to just sort of remind you of the
original algorithm which was sort of
said hey look let's take this sort of
corner of the space that we've
identified and let's do that which is
only described by a polynomial number of
things and let's do some variational
gradient descent kind of things on that
okay so that kind of ignores to some
extent you could say ignores the linear
algebra structure of this exponentially
large space when you're doing that so
let's let's head towards that
exponentially large space right just
right on and here's it here's an idea
okay it's I'm sure you've all thought
about right so it let's forget the the
actual Hamiltonian we're talking about
let's just say we have a self-adjoint
matrix a on some large space and we want
the leading eigen vector
so what do you do right you could start
with a random vector and you can just
sort of repeatedly apply the operator
right and what does that do it kind of
singles out it sort of suppresses every
other vector relative to this largest
one and the amount of that the speed at
which it suppresses this thing is the
gap between the largest eigenvalue and
the second largest eigenvalue and all
the rest you know it's presses them
others even more okay so that's the
first place where the gap comes in but
it's not the most significant place
where the gap comes in sort of a little
bit of a red herring to sort of say hey
that's why we want gap systems but sure
it's definitely if you didn't have a gap
system in that sense you'd run into
trouble already here but that's not the
real place so here's the proposal right
you start with a random starting vector
that we let's let's pick it randomly but
from this nice class right we already
have a guarantee let's suppose we have a
guarantee that in the end it's in a nice
class and let's just just repeatedly
apply a write and as we repeatedly apply
this matrix a this vector starts moving
along this along towards them they're
complex to every time right great so so
what's wrong with this picture right or
what's gonna be hard is though you
started in a nice place and you ended in
a nice place okay the problem is that
every time you apply a you increase the
complexity whatever a little bit notion
of that is and so in the middle you're
gonna end up with something very highly
complex there's no guarantee that you
won't and you will I mean that's the
likely thing and I've drawn sort of this
red thick line to say just to say that
in an exponentially large space if you
sort of pick a random vector your inner
product with the guy that you want to is
going to be on the order of 1 over 2 to
the N right
and so for most of the time and every
time you know you improve that inner
product by a constant every time you
apply a but for most of that time you're
sitting way far away right and right and
then eventually by the time you get to 1
over polynomial n angle then it goes
rather quickly only need log number of
steps after that but just sort of
pictorially for a while you're really
you know
you're not making much progress at all
in terms of anything you can see okay so
as you pointed out right what's the
problem with this approach well the
problem is that every time you apply a
the complexity or the entanglement sort
of doubles or increases by some factor
and so you can't afford even though it
only takes polynomial number of
iterations of a to get where you're
going you can't afford that your your
complexity is gonna get to be
exponential at which point you can't
work with them all right and so again as
what I said before the you know it's
it's a the beginning is fine the end is
fine but it's in the middle that's the
problem and so this sort of get is
another way to sort of think about this
is you know I had this nice picture of
the small corner right but it's not a
corner right it's sort of a spread out
thing you're starting out here where
it's fine you're gonna end up here where
you want to be right but your path is
gonna take you a long way through all
these things that you don't you can't
deal with so what do we need to kind of
get past this is we need to know how to
jump into this process towards the end
if we can jump in if we can bypass that
first part and jump in towards the end
then we're gonna be in good shape we
don't have to be that close but relative
to the size of the space we have to be
reasonably close okay so the question is
how are we gonna do that so they said
this is you know I've said it all we
have to do is jump in at the end that's
I mean you know this is a search problem
the whole problem was an exponentially
large space if somebody says oh just
jump in at the end I mean that's that's
where all the problem is so let me tell
you how we do that okay the only thing
that we have as our on our disposal
really if you think about it is whatever
the nature of the succinct descriptions
of the operators and the class of small
corners that we're thinking about that's
the only kind of added piece we know
that this this thing is gonna be
impossible if we don't use that so we're
gonna have to exploit that so you should
sort of say the mindset is hey we need
to exploit something about this fact
that everything's been laid out locally
okay so so by locally I mean you know
that this big exponentially space has
been broken up into these tensor
products of pieces okay so let me tell
you what it is we're gonna do but before
I tell you what it is we're gonna do I'm
gonna as I was writing this I was
reminded of it was it was not a friend
of mine but if several friends of mine
were present for this conversation with
somebody else when they were they were
like him
I think they really count camp
counselors so they were like 17 years
old and they were in some woods and one
of these guys was feverishly looking
around and and came up with some rock
they were sort of this misshapen rock
and he was feeling very pleased with
himself for having this rock and they
asked him you know why are you looking
for the throt were you gonna use the
rock for and he said to build a lathe
and so do you need that people know how
to lay this this is a mechanical thing
and spins and sort of used to shape
things and very precise kind of thing
and so they said well well what are you
gonna do with the lathe and they said
I'm gonna use it to build a better leave
what are you gonna do with that later
it's like well I'm gonna use that late
to build a better lathe what are you
gonna do with that lathe and they're
like well then I would have a really
good working late so I mean this is way
beyond what I was thinking about when I
was 17 but the but the picture came in
mind because we're gonna do this in
steps okay and in each step we're gonna
use the previous step to get ourselves
better and eventually we'll have
something worth dealing with who though
at the beginning we don't we have to
take small steps so let me tell you what
those steps are so our goal in the end
is to end up in this exponentially large
space with a polynomial size subspace
where all the action is so a polynomial
we're gonna try to identify a polynomial
size subspace for which the ground
states are in there somewhere
and if we can manage to do that now
we're in a sort of regular linear
algebra problem in polynomial size space
that's fine okay
so that's our goal now we're starting
with an exponentially large space where
we know all the action is and we're
gonna slowly cut that each time cutting
the exponent to taking the square root
of the essentially taking the square
root of the dimension at each step
reduce it refining to a square root of
dimensioned space that still has all the
action in it and we're gonna keep doing
that step by step until we get one big
space that has all the action in it
that's only polynomial size okay so how
are we gonna do that alright so we
should think of it so it's depicted by
this picture so this is the original
space so you should think of each of
these as copies of seed to the D okay
and what we're gonna do it each stage is
we're gonna using two at a time we're
gonna form a subspace of the space
spanned by in this case in for this case
it would be sort of two copies of C to
the D by this time it's for copies of C
to the D this time it's eight copies
right so and each of these squares is
going to represent a subspace of the big
space that's you know the big
increasingly getting bigger spaces and
what are we gonna have as a guarantee
each time the guarantee that we're gonna
have at each time is that the spaces
we're keeping around
okay if we tension them together that's
a space that's a subspace of this guy
and that subspace is going to be the
where the action still is so if we can
sort of each time keep moving here
keeping the dimension of each of these
spaces no bigger than polynomial as we
move by the time we're done we'll just
have one big space it'll be polynomial
dimension with the guarantee that all
the action is there and then we'll then
we can miraculous no not necessarily in
barian to the Hamiltonian but you know
in some sense invariant to the low
dimensional the the low-energy spaces
involved yes
also respective gap is indeed constants
then you need on the luggage weekly
mania right iteration soon you don't
have to do you mean if the spectral gap
is constant right no because so so
spectral gap being constant there's that
respect to em okay yeah so so yeah yeah
so that's an important thing to realize
because yeah otherwise you think this is
an easy process so so this is not an
easy process even with the gap you need
to do something like this even for a
constant gap because once you've
normalize the gap once we're talking
about that matrix a that we were talking
about what becomes order 1 over N and so
there your you need you need a order and
iterations of a to get yourself down to
where you need or
okay so okay so it um so let me just
sort of repeat what I said right that
we're gonna want that the ground state
at each level the things we're
constructing the ground state or the
ground the lower energy spaces are very
close or lie inside or very close to
these subspaces right and we also need
to make sure that the dimensions of each
of these things stay polynomial e
bounded of each of the pieces but it's
more than they just stay polynomial e
bounded because just polynomial bounded
eventually the number of dots inside
here right there's gonna be order n
right
at which point this is going to be a
polynomial size subspace of an
exponentially large space so we have to
make sure more than just that we have a
polynomial size web space we have to
know that we can work within that
subspace right so we need to know that
these each of these have some sort of
matrix product state description that
allows us to work in them all right so
that's our that's the program that's
what we're gonna do all right what do we
have at our disposal to do that well so
now I'm gonna just to describe what are
the what are the steps you take to go
from you know to MIT from the one lathe
to the slightly better lathe right so
here's what we do we start okay
by doing the obvious thing which is two
tensor the two pieces together right so
if we have a if we have the guarantee
that this product of these things by
themselves is a good subspace well let's
just start by 10 suring these two things
together will still will still keep
invariant the fact that we've kept in
very in fact that their action is all
they're still what's the trouble with
just okay saying okay that's great let's
move on is that the dimension of this
guy has now become the square of the
dimension of that guy okay but we need
to keep the dimensions of these guys
polynomial at all times it so we're
going to now we how now have this space
where all the action is but it's too big
we can't carry it all around so we need
to make it smaller while keeping all the
action in there so how do we do that
alright so it's a two-step process
okay the first step is we're gonna take
a random subspace
so what does that do so in terms of
goodness it makes the goodness of the
tensor product space very bad right so
if you sort of said hey this whole space
is really good at describing what's
going on now I'm going to take a random
subspace it's not going to do very well
but if I just focus on how badly it does
within this subspace it's still not
gonna do well but it's only gonna do
polynomial ii badly like one over pali
badly right so i've taken a random
subspace and whereas before I was doing
really well
now the analogy is like my angle which
used to be really close now my angle is
1 over pali away it's one of our poly
from perpendicular so so which means
that only you know a logarithmic number
of iterations would get us back there if
it's an exponentially sized space this
is a problem but these p this this space
that we're dealing with this polynomial
o so as a component space we're only
we're we're still far away but we're
polynomial a far far away so which may
which implies at least sort of if you
remember this sort of iteration
technique that if i can find the right
operator to point me in the right
direction i should only require to get
back to very close either a constant
amount or a logarithmic number of
applications of of something ok what
that thing is I'm not quite sure but
something there's hope that I can get
back there and so that's exactly what I
need to do and the way I do it because
I'm not I'm not dealing with the whole
space I'm dealing with a piece of the
space I don't know exactly what operator
I'm gonna end up applying because I
can't figure out what's going on away
but I know the components of the
operator that I'm gonna apply and so
what I'm gonna do is sort of take this
space right and throw in some operator
apply to the space and throw in some
more operators apply two powers of this
operator applied to the space and that
way I know that in that span of things I
have any operator that would be just a
linear combination in some sense of all
these different pls pieces
so again so whatever what have I done
I've started with the big space I'm
taking a random projection to cut it
down to a very small space and then I
take the image of that small space under
various operators and throw all those
pieces together so now I'm growing the
space back up again square root ya know
so the so the random projection is gonna
be smaller than the square root but but
but if I hope is that when I'm done once
it because I now grow it again but when
but when I done I'm getting back to the
square root yes No yeah and you can
modify it to be constant no this is the
separate yeah yeah and it's not even so
it is longer than can general because a
tree if you go down the worst cut is
logarithmic but the best cut is constant
so you could reshape the tree you can
show that any but that's okay so do
people that sort of basically understand
this sort of I mean it's very big I
haven't said what H restricted is I
haven't said but the but the idea is
right you're you're gonna use the fact
that cutting down you're sort of still
in a polynomial you know this is
happening over and over again you're
cutting down individually and you're
moving things back individually and
that's gonna be enough all right so to
make this work so that by the time
you've come back to here two things have
to be true right one is that using these
guys and Kent you know that's what the
resulting space is that the tensor
product of those things is going to
still be where all the action is but
that's the first thing it has to be and
this size of the space has to not be too
big that's the second addition so those
two things you need and so two you need
at this is the place where the gap
condition really comes into play so if
you need and so let me say
let me tell you very quickly we're this
h restricted comes from what'swhat's the
fact what's the what's the picture of
what it is that you need and so let me
tell you what that is you can't take
random efficiently or it's not exactly
random so with without increase in
complexity of the basis and the like so
I mean you you don't do really mean like
random lose respect I don't know two-car
measure
yes of it to you you can you can
orthogonalize things you have an
orthonormal basis now you can it
increases it by a small polynomial
factor but that factor you're sort of
including is as a overhead all of which
still will not get you back up to that
but by the terminus right through a
random space to any corner no yeah okay
so the key ingredient to sort of getting
this this this fine analysis to work is
something a notion of an approximate
ground state projection so what an
approximate ground state projection is
is it's an operator that approximately
projects onto the ground state so let me
show you what that means right so I'll
show it to you in two different ways so
the one way is it's an operator that
fixes the ground state and shrinks
everything else space every time you
apply it which if you looked at the
spectrum would mean where the ground
state in is it has an eigen value of one
and everywhere else it's eigen values
lie below Delta between Delta and minus
L so that's the picture of this would be
a delta approximate projection okay but
there's the second thing you do is that
you're going to apply this projection
right and so you don't want the
complexity to go up too much so you
don't want it to be too you don't want
the entanglement that it adds with each
application to be too big so there's
some separate measure of how much
entanglement that it adds and so you're
looking for some operator for which you
know the better you can make Delta the
smaller you can make Delta is good the
smaller you can
smaller you can make be is good and the
condition that you end up meeting is the
critical threshold is the D times Delta
is less than one you can create a
scenario where a this approximate ground
state per projector has this property
that it it's Delta and D times D is less
than one then you get the fact that
randomly projecting and reapplying this
thing gains you something and when it
gains you something it means by the time
you're back to where you were you're a
smaller dimension then you started with
and that's what you need cuz you need to
reduce the dimension from something
squared back to the something and the
construction of this projection you take
the original Hamiltonian and that's not
good you know that had a gap and so you
could imagine maybe powers of that a
good the right power of that could work
but that doesn't work that gets you
right back to where you started from you
need better than that and the way you
get better than that is something that
some people may be familiar with is or
shouldn't be surprised by is you end up
choosing a chebyshev polynomial in the
hamiltonian so the app know you and you
end up scaling you end up scaling things
down so that all the app you know so
that the spectrum is between 0 and 1 and
then you do attribute 'href polynomial
on that scaled version you Joseph
this is what actually people do in
America yeah and that's where I mean
that's when you just borrow his tools
for that okay so that's pretty much it
so let me just sort of give you a
summary so of the pieces right so again
this was just to say the thing that I
said a bunch of times right the picture
is we've got to succinctly describe very
big matrix of which we're trying to find
the some principal eigenvector and so
what were the tools one was how do we
talk about the vectors in that space
that was the matrix product States
anymore in general tensor networks or a
good language for that they succinctly
describe things that that Express
relatively complex vectors and they're
very orthogonal if you're thinking like
sparse as another way of identifying a
big matrix using just sort of things
identifying that it's sparse this is
very different from that these are not
and then we've exploited the locality of
the problem to sort of build up so that
we had a place to jump in and doing that
building up that sort of modular
building up involved two basic ideas one
was the idea of a random projection this
is because you kind of don't really know
where you're going so the randomness
gets you that concentration of getting
on average behavior that you want and
then building it back up using an
approximate ground state projection
which was what gave you the advantage
that you thought you would get from this
randomness and the building back up and
then finally just to remind you the
final step when we get down to the end
right is a polynomial subspace inside an
exponentially large space and at that
point you since the polynomial subspace
is described by matrix products gates
you can just do linear algebra they are
restrict the Hamiltonian to that space
and then you just write down that
polynomial by polynomial matrix that
you're trying to all that will give you
the coefficients that'll give you the
coefficient the linear combination of
the matrix product States that you had
to do that and that's right thing
so so if you want to bloom again the
trustees using this construction so to
get the bound he has this relationship
between gap and that being that the
measure of the document as you result
you mean the result you mention gives
others if you have care because this
simple representation and is there bound
which connects the measure of
entanglement to the gap yes there is and
I remember it but there is some phone
there is some map so you recover the
same bones I think it's a better map you
get better so you but you again to
double your sake you need to start with
some guys a priori bone you start with a
gap you stop the god god gift gap gives
you that those in the the fundamental
yes yes so the Badminton ends ups but
you need to start with some one
dimension for your construction yeah so
so the a special one so it's some
function of epsilon which I'd forgotten
right this minute together
yeah have one over the guy who gets
likely to be good
no the whole the whole thing ends up
being a bound of oh so you're saying
what what how much do I have to maintain
it'll at every step
yeah it's um it's polynomial in N and
some function of one a repla and what is
like that they're like the big two here
so it looks like it's a it's a tricky
thing but are they maintained or what
this is their big to be a big tool yes I
think the mathematical tool is the
existence proving the existence of the
ages P so so that the thing is why does
you know the the the the result is why
this works
I mean it's then it works it's a proof
that it works and the fact that it works
has to do with the construction of this
HSP and being able to prove that that
construction has its D and its Delta in
this proper proper range it doesn't add
up to much entanglement for the amount
of cutting down
so why is all structure if you go to two
dimensional system yes that's a good
question
so the obstruction is essentially that
we can't get an Ag SP for that scenario
so there are two obstructions okay so
the first obstruction is just the
problem in itself you have NP problems
in the two-dimensional picture just
possibly right so you know it's not
going to work without something right
but you could still hope for an aerial
law type move without an algorithm you
could hope for an aerial law and for
that so then you would sort of say okay
can we make this a GSP construction work
for that and see so yeah so so there the
problem is you know your D which which
is the amount of entanglement that you
increase in two dimensions you're sort
of dealing with a square and so you end
up with this perimeter of that square
coming in as a factor separate from the
D there's a D times this is perimeter
and that you can't that's just too much
to overcome in your Delta you can't rig
your delta to be smaller than the amount
of a tank like this at least the ways
we've thought about race
what is that Aryan or what is it what
does it say okay so the area law in in
general is something that physicists
believe to work in any dimension but so
let's just let me just describe it let
me go back to the two dimensions in one
dimension picture
so in in in one-dimension the area law
says hey the the ground state the lowest
energy state is going to have the
property that if I make a cut the
entanglement across the cut should scale
by the number of the the the quote area
that that the corresponds to the cut so
in one dimension it should be it scales
as a constant and into Dement and so I
was drawing it as poly n which is a
little bit bigger than a cop which turns
out to be a little correspond to a
little bit or in accosted but that's
just because the translations of
different notions of entanglement but
for true dimensions it would mean that
the entanglement in general could be as
big as the volume but you physicists
expect for the ground state it should be
as big as the size of the square root so
in this case the square root well yeah
the square root in the exponent you
don't need it because you proved it
right you proved that it works right in
this one yeah yeah so that one there is
no known area law despite the fact that
physicists really believe it's true oh
okay I see so physicists will say
there's an area a lot the same the same
procedure eraser is analog will not work
here like merging two things right so
that was sort of akin to the question
that that asked me which was that in two
dimensions the amount of complexity that
you add scales you know like a perimeter
and that so it's much bigger and you
can't somehow so you wouldn't do so you
cannot do a little bit to grow right
cases you have to have the boundaries
zero-dimensional
for for with this include this
restriction yes yeah is the kind of a
complexity theoretical structure
essentially here you proved it from
certain colossal zoos big matrices most
arching a polynomial time algorithm now
you have would say something another
class is different from unclear whether
this clear whether there are it's
unclear whether this area law holds in
more than one dimension nobody but but
that don't you play a question for
matrices which shows up you know it is
they're hopeful set to prove that
something hard that you cannot
approximate those eigenvalues oh sorry
sorry okay
so let's make a distinction between an
area law type statement which is a
statement that the final solution has a
certain form and then there's a more
harder question is can we find that one
okay for the second question for sure
there's an obstruction there's just
classically on two dimensions there's a
satisfying you know a constraint
satisfaction problem there are plenty
that are np-hard so this means that you
can expected losses you cannot expect to
do okay so this is this is another
explanation by by dimensional this
gentle ball in two dimensional that is
but there's this there's the the the
first statement which is is the answer
of a certain forum it doesn't cover that
and that is the thing that physicists do
believe is true
okay baby okay thanks Allah
[Applause]